so if I were giving advice to someone
who wants to work in the field of
software buttocks I would say that you
know so so learning robotics is already
a very very multidisciplinary thing so
you know you know you're mechanical you
know you're electrical you know you're
software you know you're there's all
these skills you need to take on so you
know easy enough take on a few more you
know who doesn't like learning so you
know learn about learn about your
chemistry's particularly your polymer
chemistry's learn about chemical
engineering and the way in which
manufacturers convert raw chemical
materials into sophisticated
you know mechanical constructs and
electrical constructs also learn about
biomechanics so you know the the some of
the greatest machines ever created are
found in nature natural systems do
things incredibly efficiently with
minimal computation relative to what
what's seen in the robots that we as a
society built today so I would heavily
encourage people to learn a lot more
about biological systems to draw
inspiration to create inspired new
mechanisms